As we go to your next game,
Master of Seduction.
Our good buddies at the Found
Footage Festival turned us on
to this '80s gem called
The Video Guide
for Successful Seduction.
You should watch it.
It totally all works.
Our favorite seducer
is this guy,
telling us how to pick up
a lady in Detroit. Take notes.
Detroit: you need a dollar,
a 12-pack of beer,
a gram of coke,
and a whip.
Uh...
What?
Now, comedians, I'm sure Norm
from Cheers After Dark here
has a trick for... every city,
so I would like you to give me
as many other cities as you can
and what you should put
in your seduction kit
to get some local ass
in 60 seconds. And begin.
-Uh, Esther.
-Los Angeles: a weed card,
green juice, and a Kickstarter
for all the plastic surgery.
Points. Ryan Stout.
Tijuana: a donkey
with zebra stripes,
a greased fist, and a wristwatch
you don't mind losing.
All right, points.
Uh, Brandon.
Okay. Madrid, Spain:
eight bottles of wine,
a carton of cigarettes,
and, uh, some guy's wife.
Points. Ryan.
Tirana, Albania:
a young kid who can lure
backpackers into a van,
a backpacker, and a van.
All right, points. Yeah. Those
are all the things you need.
Esther.
Iowa: Hillary Clinton pantsuit,
Bernie Sanders wig,
and Donald Trump's willingness
to have sex with anyone
including his daughter.
Yes, points.
Brandon.
Uh, Narnia.
Oh. Yes.
Narnia.
A lion, a witch, and a wardrobe.